sometimes it feels like uh he and others
uh they're building things in this world
successfully are basically uh
confidently exploring a dark room
with a very confident ambitious Vision
with that room actually looks like
like
they're just walking straight into the
darkness there's no painful toys or
Legos on the ground I'm just going to
walk I know exactly how far the wall is
and then very quickly willing to adjust
as they run into they step on the Lego
and or their their body uh is filled
with a lot of pain what I mean by that
is there's this kind of evolution that
seems to happen where you discover
really good ideas along the way that
allow you to Pivot like to me
since you know since a few years ago
when you could see with Andre karapathi
the software 2.0 evolution of autopilot
it became obvious to me that this is not
about the car
this is about Optimus the robot
this is this is like if we look back 100
years from now
the car will be remembered as a cool car
nice Transportation but the the
autopilot won't be the thing that
controls the car it would be the thing
that allows embodied AI systems to
understand the world so broadly and so
that kind of approach and it's and you
kind of stumble into it well Tesla be a
a car company
will it be an AI company will it be a
robotics company will it be a home
robotics company will be an energy
company and you kind of slowly discover
this as you confidently uh
like push forward with a vision so it's
interesting to watch that kind of
evolution as long as it's backed by this
confidence there are a couple of things
that are required for that one is being
adventurous one doesn't enter a dark
room without a flashlight and a map
unless you're a risk taker unless you're
adventurous the second is to have
iterative uh brain Cycles where you can
process information
and do a feedback loop and make it work
the third and this is what we failed to
do a lot in the United States and
perhaps around the world is when you
take risks you have to realize you're
going to blow things up
you know first three rockets that the
Falcon rockets that must does they blow
up even Starship three and a half
minutes but then it blows up the first
time so I think Boeing and NASA and
others have become
unwilling to enter your dark room
without knowing exactly where the exit
is and the lighted path to the exit
and the people who created America
whenever they came over you know whether
the Mayflower is refugees from the Nazis
they took a lot of risk to get here and
now I think we have more referees than
we have Risk Takers more
lawyers and regulators and others saying
you can't do that that's too risky then
people willing to innovate and you need
both I think you're also right on 50 100
years from now
what musk will be most remembered for
besides space travel
is real world AI
uh not just Optimus the robot but
Optimus robot and the self-driving car
uh they're they're pretty much the same
they're using
uh you know GPU clusters or Dojo chips
or whatever it may be to process real
world data we all got and you did on
your podcast quite excited about large
language model you know generative uh
predictive text AI That's fine
especially if you want to chit chat with
your chat but
but the Holy Grail is artificial general
intelligence and the tough part of that
is real world AI
and that's where Optimus the robot or
full self Drive
or I think far ahead of anybody else